Southern blot is a probe-based method to
identify specific DNA molecules among
many other DNA molecules this was
devised by Edwin sardon at 1975. this
technique starts with gel
electrophoresis where a mixture of DNA
molecules is loaded and separated in
agarose gel later on DNA is transfer
fired into a nitrocellulose membrane
then there is a blotting step where the
DNA from the gel moves to the membrane
the DNA trans that once the DNA is
transferred to the membrane then it
could be used for probe hybridization
this probe is actually against the DNA
of Interest
now the after probe hybridization one
can look at the signal while developing
it in an autoradiograph these days
autoradiograph are not used but anyway
this was an ancient technique which was
very useful at its time
watch the full video to know more